there are so many scenes throughout the
Harry Potter series that heavily rely on
practical effects to bring that Hogwarts
magic to life I'm talking practical
flying broomsticks very dangerous remote
controlled trees and an animatronic
snake that may not look super realistic
but definitely gets the job done the
intense game of Wizard's Chest that
Harry Ron and Hermione had to get
through in order to get to the
Sorcerer's Stone had super high stakes
also the fact that the film's production
designer Stuart Craig actually created
it is majorly impressive they were moved
around on the board by a radio control
mechanism and the horse that explodes
unfortunately with Ron still on it was
set up with a compressed air device
inside of it the incredibly dangerous
tree in Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets that attacks Ron's flying car
was created using a combination of
practical effects and CGI the actual
tree was built on a hydraulic platform
that could be controlled by the special
effects team to simulate its movements
I'm really wondering how scared the cast
was during all the takes of those scenes
now let's talk about the giant serpent
that Harry battles in the Chamber of
Secrets it was created using a
combination of animatronics and puppetry
first a life-sized model was built on
set which had a full team to control its
movements and facial expressions it was
then mounted on a track system which
allowed it to move through the set and
interact with the actors there was also
just a separate head created and used
for specific shots the model was also
covered in real snake skin which was
sourced from a snake Farm of course
though they had to finish it off with a
bit of CGI to enhance and finalize its
movement and texture in post-production
the triple decker bus that transports
Harry to the Leaky cauldron in the
Prisoner of Azkaban was built as a
practical prop that could actually be
driven the bus was created using a real
London route Master bus that was is
modified and painted purple for the film
the hippogriff that Harry and Hagrid
encounter was actually created using a
combination of practical effects and CGI
a life-sized animatronic model was built
for the actors to interact with it could
move it just looked alive you've just
never seen anything like it while the
more complex flying sequences were
created using CGI for all the wide shots
where Buckbeak had to fly a huge puppet
was mounted on a crane and operated by a
team which allowed it to move through
the air as well as interact with the
actors they even added feathers to the
puppet by hand to make it look more
realistic the magical object that
selects the tri-wizard Champions was
created as a practical prop that could
actually shoot Flames the prop was built
using a combination of metal and
fiberglass and required extensive safety
precautions to make sure that the actors
were safe throughout the scenes it was
used for I can't imagine how much of a
liability shooting flames would be the
room of requirements First shows up in
Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix it's a magical space that
appears only when someone really needs
it it was created as a practical set
that could physically transform the set
was built with moving walls and objects
that could be controlled by the special
effects team to create the illusion of
the room changing to suit the
character's needs the giant serpent that
accompanies Lord Voldemort in Deathly
Hallows part 1 was created using a
combination of practical effects and CGI
a life-sized animatronic model was built
for the actors to interact with it was
operated by a full team of puppeteers
then in post-production they replaced
the snake's movement with CGI which
allowed the production team to capture
the movement and behavior of a real
snake while still having the flexibility
to make changes later in the film's
Quidditch scenes in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone the actors were
actually suspended on harnesses and
flown around the set to create the
illusion of flying on broomsticks this
involved a complex rigging system and
required everyone to undergo extensive
training to perform the stunts safely
you would think it would be a ton of fun
to ride broomsticks all day but
apparently the actors would often
complain about being sore and often
dread having to do these scenes because
the brooms were so uncomfortable I was
not the slightest bit upset when Harry
broke the no magic outside of Hogwarts
rule to inflate his rude Aunt Marge up
like a balloon I was also quite
impressed to find out that the scene was
not done with CGI Pam Ferris had to go
through four different makeup stages and
wore body suits pumped full of air her
hands and legs had to be inflated
separately she was lifted with wires and
her movements were controlled by rigs
that spun her around so even though CGI
has become increasingly prevalent in
modern filmmaking these practical
effects helped to ground the Fantastical
elements of the story in a sense of
physical reality May making the World of
Harry Potter feel all the more tangible
and immersive I truly never would have
guessed Aunt Marge didn't need any help
with CGI to float off into the abyss or
that Wizard's Chest is more or less
life-threatening what were you most
surprised to learn was fully practical
[Music]